[Music]
well i don't trust red wings
hold on a minute you don't have to trust
red wig
but i'm gonna go see if he's right cause
i have a feeling they might be a part of
the big three
what big three the big three white big
three androids aliens and wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely it
no it's not every time we fight we fight
one of the three so who are you fighting
now gandalf
yep how do you know about gandalf i read
the hobbit
in 1937 when it first came out so you
see my point
no i don't there are no wizards dr
strange is a sorcerer
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
think about it right i'm right i just i
just came up with that it's crazy
look that's not the point these guys
aren't magical all right they use brute
force just like you
the incredibly annoying guy in front of
me with the staring problem i'm coming
with you no you're not
so who would like to start
mr barnes why does sam aggravate you
15 seconds to drop so what's our plan
hey great
superheroes cannot be allowed
to exist
i have no intention to leave my work i'm
finished
[Music]
the wall's upside down right now
where do we start
[Applause]
i have a plan oh yeah what is it
here we go again huh
[Applause]
hello girl kick your ass
[Music]
see that wasn't so hard are you ready
is you ready ready okay what are you
doing ready
are you having a staring contest are you
ready
just blank sweet jesus i mean how old
are you
[Music]
you